revisamos el tiempo todos los días a lo
largo de cada día pero alguna vez te has
preguntado de dónde viene controlar el
tiempo por qué es importante saber qué
hora es quién inventó el reloj y por qué
caramba existen tantos osos horarios
diferentes la primera forma de medir el
tiempo fue el reloj de sol y los
primeros relojes solares de los que se
tiene noticia son los obeliscos que
datan desde hace cinco mil años los
relojes solares indican el tiempo
proyectando una sombra sobre una
superficie el objeto que proyecta la
sombra es un palo colocado en el centro
llamado gnomon un reloj solar bien
construido puede medir el tiempo con
gran precisión incluso se han usado para
monitorear el funcionamiento de los
relojes hasta la era moderna pero los
relojes solares tienen sus limitaciones
necesitan que el sol brille por lo tanto
no funcionan de noche cuando estaba
obscuro muchos dispositivos han sido
usados con el paso del tiempo para
estimar su paso por ejemplo velas y
varas de incienso que se consumen a una
velocidad estimada usada junto con el
reloj de arena los relojes de arena
contienen arena muy fina
qué pasa por un orificio a una velocidad
constante e indica un periodo de tiempo
determinado por el paso de la arena a
través de éste sin embargo el origen de
reloj de arena es incierto aunque a
comienzos del siglo 14 el reloj de arena
era comúnmente usado especialmente a
bordo de los barcos ya que el movimiento
del barco no afectaba el reloj de arena
a diferencia de otros dispositivos
el reloj mecánico fue inventado en el
siglo 13 lo que desató un gran cambio en
la manera de medir el tiempo el reloj
moderno se basó en el balanceo de un
péndulo la vibración de un cristal de
cuarzo que era mucho más preciso que un
reloj de arena hoy la base del tiempo
científico es un conteo continuo de
segundos basado en relojes atómicos
alrededor del mundo conocido como tiempo
atómico internacional porque es
importante medir el tiempo el tiempo
regular nuestra vida diaria y hace
posible que nos comuniquemos con otros
de manera precisa alrededor del mundo
sin un sistema tendríamos problemas con
el cultivo las estructuras sociales las
comunicaciones y los negocios tomemos
como ejemplo el sistema ferroviario
estado
a mediados del siglo 19 cada ferrocarril
lo usaba su propio horario pasado
generalmente en la hora local de la
oficina central y los horarios de los
trenes se publicaban usando su propio
huso horario algunos de los cruces de
carriles más importantes servían a
diferentes ferrocarriles y tenían un
reloj para cada ferrocarril cada uno con
su diferente huso horario
la distancia entre nueva york y boston
es de 2 grados 8 minutos lo cual puede
hacer la diferencia entre llegar o
perder la conexión de tren si la
diferencia entre nueva york y boston es
de 8 minutos imagina la diferencia entre
boston y australia los husos horarios
nivelan esas diferencias y hacen las
comunicaciones mucho más sencillas unos
horarios una región en la tierra que
tiene un tiempo estándar uniforme
existen 40 husos horarios en la tierra
porque del uso más temprano al más tarde
hay 26 horas de diferencia cualquier
fecha del calendario existe en algún
punto del planeta por 50 horas así que
la próxima vez que alguien te pregunte
qué hora es tu respuesta podría ser
mucho más complicada de lo que solía ser